sur les plages leur présence est plutôt
discrète ils sont pourtant omniprésent
des déchets en plastique en tous genres
qui jonchent les plages même entretenu
équipés de poubelles depuis le 1er
janvier
certains de ces plastiques à usage
unique sont interdits
je pense que c'est une bonne chose quand
même la nature sa banque au plus haut et
pour maintenir fait semblant de lui
parler et sa retraite bien qu'elle a
passé quelques belles pages
je suis très plastique je n'aime pas
faire la vaisselle
vous allez faire alors je sais pas
j'aviserai j'avais déjà fermé réservé
pour papa parmi les produits interdits
les assiettes en plastique jetables dans
ce magasin spécialisé
les solutions alternatives ne manquent
pas dallas vous trouve effectivement des
barquettes en bambou tous ces produits
là vous avez des verrines en bambou vous
avez aussi du bois
vous avez aussi la pulpe de canne ici
les produits en plus faut des cales en
bois très apprécié et le palmier exit
aussi les gobelets de la machine à café
puis si nous nous trouvons un produit
novateur pour les distributeurs à eau
donc pour les collectivités les
entreprises donc sous forme conique et
c'est un petit gobelet en carton
donc une fois vous avez fini de boire
pour le prenez vous le compresser et
vous le mettez à la poubelle en réalité
le plastique ne va pas totalement
disparaître ce que vise la loi c'est le
plastique à usage unique et la frontière
est parfois subtiles
regardez ces deux paquets de flûtes à
champagne qui semble en tous points
identique celui de droite est désormais
interdit celui de gauche autorisée grâce
à la mention qui s'y trouvent un
plastique lavables et réutilisables
résistant à 20 passages de lave
vaisselle en théorie les magasins
jusqu'à six mois pour se débarrasser des
produits interdits
un délai plus difficile à tenir chez
nous à cause de l'éloignement avec
l'hexagone amara c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué en terme de logistique
les pays qui sont en france pour
l'europe ils ont un stock peut-être sur
une haine sur une semaine pardon - moi
on doit fonctionner sur des sommes de
trois mois
où voir six mois pour certains produits
donc quand on nous dit effectivement
qu'il faut faire ce changement dont
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour nous
d'écouler ses stocks là à terme la
france vise la fin du plastique à usage
unique d'ici 2040
on estime à 100 mille le nombre de
mammifères et à plus d'un million le
nombre d'animaux marins qui meurent
chaque année dans le monde à cause de la
gestion de ces plastiques dans certains
cas ils provoquent perforation et
occlusion intestinale à cause d'un autre
objet désormais lui aussi interdit le
coton tige